and action  how's it going xiaomi and gabon joe  miller  get off of me  does he look like he can fight  [Music]  the moment that i was cast for chongqi i  was like nervous slash anxious slash  excited never thought that i would be  marvel's first asian superhero  well you're really good  i showed up from the first day of  training and i just got my butt kicked  oh panic at the disco  we explored what his strengths were we  also covered all his weaknesses what  weaknesses  training that he went through mirrored  the character  [Music]  the sets were incredible everything's  been carefully designed no screw you i'm  not doing this  [Music]  i'm working with some of the best in the  business  i've never seen a superhero that looks  something like me  movies like this allows kids to feel the  possibilities  it was such a profound moment for me as  a fan as an actor as an asian person